moi j'aime bien faire la lessive si une
excellent dynastique
et puis ça donne les muscles ça que tu
sais moi ça m'a peut-être pas tellement
d'avoir des muscs et puis en ce qui
concerne la gymnastique mais cours de
danse sont plus amusant mais c'est aussi
plus risqués pourquoi dit issa et bien
que le jour au casimir te marche pas sur
les pieds tu voudras plusieurs jours
pourtant n'être ce que tu faisais je
suis sûr que casimir ne marchera pas sur
les pieds y danse très bien c'est vrai
c'est vrai ils en sont très bien il doit
il n'est pas encore venu faire sa
lessive ce gros paresseux il doit avoir
encore attraper une indigestion de
l'oubli boulga tu sais il faudrait
surveiller sa nourriture faire attention
à ce qu'elle soit plus légère plus à moi
je ne sais pas il faudrait que tu t'en
occupes mais je l'aimé je m'en suis
occupé mais avec toute cette lessive
j'ai pas eu le temps d'en parler j'ai
une idée
on va lui faire manger des spaghettis
spaghettis tu crois qu'ils adressent pas
russe a certainement de sélestat getty
c'est très nourrissant leur salut
rappellera un petit peu le le
gloubiboulga après tu vas pour les
spaghettis je les laisse ta lessive une
seconde et vient avec moi tu vas voir ce
que tu vas voir regarde que dis-tu de
saint brais rien qu'est ce que c'est que
cet appareil est bien c'est une machine
à faire des spaghettis regarde comment
ça marche tu mets la partie ci devra
ensuite tu tourne la manivelle il de
l'autre côté par cette trappe
gaiffe du recteur des spaghettis bien
serait plus qu'à les faire cuire
je suis sûr que ça me fera beaucoup
casimir de faire lui même c'est pas trop
c'est formidable
françois j'espère qu'il va aimer les
spaghettis j'en suis certain en
attendant j'aimerais bien qu'il fasse sa
lessive
ouais bon bah écoute il va sûrement
venir mais nous allons terminer la nôtre
oui
je fasse tout ma lessive à la main
j'y arriverai jamais bonjour vous êtes
là oh la la moi ça ne va pas du tout je
suis très en colère il faut que je fasse
ma lessive à la main
j'aime pas ça je devais la faire avec la
machine à laver que devait m'envoyer ma
tante phrase il devait arriver
aujourd'hui il rien et là j'étais
seulement reçu le mode d'emploi
il faut pourtant absolument que je
nettoie mon costume de mousquetaires
qu'est ce que c'est que ça on dirait ma
machine à laver
mais oui au jeu c'est formidable facteur
l'année juste à temps j'avais quand même
pouvoir laver mon linge
[Musique]
voilà elle est belle hein bon alors
comment est ce que l'on procède d'abord
premièrement mettez de l'eau de l'eau de
l'eau bon là j'aurais utilisé lors le
tuyau d'arrosage que françois utilisent
pour le pour les fleurs voilà up de
l'eau très bien deuxièmement mettez le
linge sale dans la machine évidemment le
linge sale
voilà hop voilà c'est ça a l'air très
pratique
troisièmement mettez de la lessive
lessive
et voilà quatrièmement tournée
énergiquement la manivelle la manivelle
art alicja côté très bien et ça c'est
rigolo
casimir a déjà trouvé la machine à faire
des spaghettis
c'est formidable il est déjà en train
d'en confectionner
voilà je crois que ça suffit
cinquièmement ouvrait la crap
j'ai récupéré vos problèmes vous n'aurez
plus qu'à les tendres pour qu'il sèche
voilà ça alors ça alors c'est pile drôle
de spaghettis
casimir encore fabriqué mon costume de
mousquetaires mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé quand vous êtes là pour les deux
regardez la machine à l'arrêt de ma
tante phrase y est complètement d'être
athées etc estimé
mais c'est pas une machine à la téloche
qu'est ce que c'est alors un éléphant
une tour eiffel mais c'est une machine à
fabriquer les spaghettis spaghettis tu
es sûr bien sûr c'est françois qui l'a
fait amené exprès pour toi des
spaghettis mais alors que mon beau
costume de mousquetaires écoute je peux
essayer d'aider à te recoudre n'est
n'est ce pas des teams aimé mais c'est
épouvantable mais qu'est-ce que ça des
spaghettis au fait ce sont des pas très
fine et très longue
c'est le plat national italien était
qu'est-ce que c'est un plat national
la nationale est bien c c'est un black
quelques légendes un pays préfèrent
manger et souvent pour les jours de fête
d'ailleurs on mais s'avère très bien et
coûtent pas un mois un petit peu de tout
c'est platon soit à chaque pays a sa
spécialité
oui écoute quasi nul même ferme il nous
allons offrir un jeu je viens tous les
ans les enfants des enfants venez nous
allons faire un jeu installez vous voyez
il venait vous n'y prenez je vais vous
donner un certain langage de plats et
vous allez me dire leur pays d'origine
za d'accord il vous si chez vous eh bien
je commence sont d'accord alors nous
avons les spaghettis n'ont pas de france
à l'origine les spaghettis viennent
d'italie très bien là que casimir retard
est pas trompé non ensuite la paix ya
rien à perdre
d'espagne très bien le bifteck frites
ici ah oui à la france
ici on n'est pas en france c'est l'île
aux enfants mais ça vient de france le
couscous ou couscous amérique du nord
très bien la fondue au fromage de suis
suis marche ça vient de la russie
le riz